FACE-OFF. PERFORMANCE AND
OILERS LED B GIVE McDAVID
RESPECT AND KANE, ANOTHER EIGHT
>> Jody: HE'S FOUND A H
GOALTENDER, ONE-ON-ONE, YOU CAN
SEE THE ANGLE OUTSTANDING
STOP BY ELVIS MERZLIKINS, MOVES
HAD TO BE VORACEK,
SCOR THE BACK OF THE
NET. WAITING IN THE SLOT, A
WRIST SHOT,AND THE NUMBERS IMPR
IN THE OFFENSIVE 50 PLUS POINTS.
HE HAD KOSKINEN BEAT, JACKETS
GET ANOTHER OPPORTUNITY, HOW AB
ROSLOVIC, SETTLES NET.
GREAT JOB BY JAKE BLOCKER.
OILERS HAVE IT BEHIND THE ICE,
OFF THE CROSS BAR
CENTERING PASS OFF KURALY, AND
DIVINGEGROUP FOR THE BLUE
JACKETS, BUT GET THROUGH THE
OFFENSIVE PLAYER.
GOOD JOB BY KURALY TOIE IT ANDAO
THE NET AS BJORKSTRAND COMES IN.
TIMES IT SLOWS
IT DOWN, DROPS IT  A TURNOVER.
AND AS McDAVID GETS IT, HE'S SO
KILL ADDED EXTRA, TOO, LIMITING
THE FIRST NHL GOAL AND IT'S A
POWER PLAY GOAL.
3-2 COLUMBUS!EVERYONE,
INCLUDING KOSKINEN.
AND HE'S GOT HIS FIRST IN FRONT
ROSLOVIC, HE SCORES!
JACK ROSLOVIC, THE JACKETS LEAD
BY ROSLOVIC TO GET
IN PERFECT POSITION, JAKE
ERE FOR THE
BLUE JACKETS COMING INTO THE